it's a great sense of pessimism and the
danger always is that you didn't get
almost sort of talk yourself into your
depression indeed you know into a slow
down how do we hear the word Paul says
as pulses that well every day all the
times actually so this poll is a
quarterly survey it carried out over 500
10 investors traders and analysts that
do use a blue bush is very accurate
November the 11th 212 was when it was
last carried out so before then it was
in July so this one as you say we shut
again it's not my bleep let's go with
the uptick uptick is the US who is here
she's always look at the glass half full
first time a bet on fri off today the
uptick morning even or wherever you
aren't going nothing but the u.s. is the
positive it's actually the only silver
lining in this quite a dark cloud and
there's you see that the u.s. recovering
the end of quantitative easing is a
signal towards that and actually as you
know yes I talked to James go when the
CEO and chairman Stanley he again was
also very positive on the US yes the US
recovery here he is now much more around
confidence in emotion than it is around
facts now you know our economist and not
as not as positive on the outlook in
terms of movements in the rates for
example as I am but I see QE coming off
as a very very important indication that
the US economy is recovering
they go again kitty who's saying that
and blast the bright spot is quite right
this this pork roast comes after his
comments yesterday nevertheless the
Bleak spot is that 89% see European
deflation as a risk thirty-eight percent
to the global economy worsening that's
up from eighteen percent of July more
than half see the BRIC countries
worsening to their Brazil Russia India
China that's up for thirty-six percent
or third and July the euro as a major
concern rush odd two-thirds of the euro
land weakening because there's no fiscal
policy can't leave old ECB and the ECB
me was too restrictive you got in fact
forty-two percent say it's too
restrictive that's up from july's
thirty-one percent well finally underway
have any names in this fire line here as
well he would play a druggie and also
angela merkel the two names to get
picked out by a druggie their opposites
aren't they effectively there yeah they
are but fifty-nine percent view dr e
there it is as favorably that's down
from seventy-four percent in July's last
poll meanwhile Angela Merkel German
Chancellor as a forty five percent
approval rating if you like auto
policies in these partner on a policies
which is down from seventy two percent
as the lowest in three years so that's
the sort of verdict up by this poll on
them